just because an idea is bad doesn't mean
that it won't continue to get more and
more
oxygen and become more and more
prevalent if it's politically
advantageous or serve somebody's
political interests
and we are seeing the very strong return
of the idea of pushing for herd immunity
when it comes
to coronavirus in the united states from
the trump administration donald trump
has brought on a new
i i guess he's calling him a coronavirus
advisor his name is scott atlas now the
guy is a doctor
but he's really more of a political
figure than a medical figure because he
is a neuroradiologist which as you might
notice
does not have very much to do with
infectious disease and
pandemic science but he is a part of the
conservative
think tank the hoover institution and
he's increasingly talking about going in
the direction of the sweden model
and even beyond into the herd immunity
bottle and there's a lot to talk about
here
i want to make sure everybody
understands why this is so
pernicious and dangerous so herd
immunity
is the idea that once enough of your
population of a population is immune to
a disease
you have a sort of group resistance to
it
enough people are immune that it is
unlikely that the reproduction rate of
the disease
is going to become high enough to create
a pandemic type
situation because there aren't just
there just aren't going to be enough
people left in the population
susceptible to the
disease now typically the way
in the modern human era we achieve herd
immunity
is through vaccination if you vaccinate
a large swath of the population
that's how you generate herd immunity
you're not typically generating it
through
people just getting sick and recovering
naturally now depending on how
contagious
a disease is the percentage of the
population that needs to be immune
varies so for example we're putting up
on the screen sort of a
scale of diseases of different levels of
contagion
if you look at measles measles is so
contagious it has a reproduction rate
between 12 and 18
that in order to get hurt immunity you
need
somewhere between 92 and 95 of the
population
to be immune either through having
recovered from the disease
uh or vaccination or usually it's a
combination of the two
if you look sort of in the middle you've
got mumps
mumps has a reproduction rate an r
naught of four to seven
so because it's less contagious than
measles you need somewhere between
75 and 86 of the population
to be immune to get hurt immunity and as
you can see
if you're looking at this chart
coronavirus
is estimated to have a reproduction rate
of somewhere between
two and six meaning that somewhere
between
50 and 83 of the population
need immunity for us to have what we
would call
herd immunity so that brings us to this
neuroradiologist scott atlas who donald
trump has brought in and he's cheering
and saying it's so great to have scott
involved what he wants is more
of the sweden model and more of a push
for herd immunity as a way to get beyond
coronavirus and the pandemic the numbers
if you think about them are really
really ugly so
i told you that we for coronavirus to
reach herd immunity
we need between 50 and 83 of the
population to be immune
let's just pick a number that's right in
the middle there okay we'll call it
67 for just to pick a number uh
let's assume for a second remember we
have to assume
that recovering from the virus gives you
immunity
for a significant period of time we're
still trying to figure that out
and number two let's even assume
officially we've had 6.1 million cases
in the united states
let's imagine we've really had twice as
many okay
let's imagine we've only found
officially
half of the cases so even though the
official number is six
let's imagine we've had 12 million cases
in the united states
with 331 million people in this country
if we've had 12 million cases that means
right now
3.6 percent of the population uh
is immune presumably if nobody gets the
vaccine
in order to get to herd immunity which
means 67 percent of the population
that would be 222 million cases right
two-thirds of 331 million is 222.
if you understand that we have about a
one percent death rate
that means that to get to herd immunity
the u.s would suffer
2.2 million deaths
so far only 187
000 have died an unconscionable number
but less than 10 percent of what we
would expect
if we were to go to herd immunity
without a vaccine
so that would mean that if we do what
scott atlas wants
and the other herd immunity advocates we
still have
2 million deaths to come now what might
change that number if we get really good
at treating the virus
and we can reduce the death rate for
example from one percent to 0.5 percent
then we would have one million more
people die
on the way to herd immunity now the
problem is that there's another side to
that
which is if we have this many cases
over a relatively short period of time
because we just open it back
up and let it rip the hospitals will
become overloaded and what we do know
is that the death rate goes up when
hospitals get very very full
so this is sort of again going back to
this
we've really tried nothing yet and we're
out of ideas
we've not really had a coordinated
national lockdown we never really did
a six-week serious shutdown and now
we're heading
into flu season and what many infectious
disease doctors
expect to be at this point calling it a
second wave doesn't even make sense
because we've never really gotten down
below
30 000 cases a day for months and months
but this is the approach that they now
have now on the other side
remember nobody's calling for a forever
shutdown
or forever closures or anything what
we're talking about right now
in a modestly optimistic scenario
um is another few months
we expect some vaccine to be approved in
the next couple of months we expect it
to start being available by the end of
the year
we expect that it will be reasonably
affected
and we expect that most of the
population in the u.s
who wants the vaccine which is a whole
other problem
is going to be able to get it by the
start of the spring of 2021. that may
change
but does nobody understand delayed
gratification here we are getting closer
and the approach that donald trump
increasingly wants to take of pretending
that this is basically in the rear view
mirror
while pushing for herd immunity through
some of his followers
and staff is a very dangerous idea and
the simple numbers explain why